as we covered yesterday there is a new
president in Argentina Javier Malay he
is now the president of Argentina
because they have had massive government
growth complete devaluation of their
currency they have had a creeping
socialism for a long time craziness with
gender stuff and all of the woke stuff
and he has come in to absolutely
obliterate it and listen to him uh
talking about why you must fight the
Socialists and the wers and the people
who want that ever encroaching
government which is directly connected
to what Elon just said Donald Trump is
running for president again in the
United States as you know what advice
would you give
him
for
you get it you get it so the people of
San Francisco the people of California
they let it in they let it spread they
didn't fight most of the people elected
the very people who ushered it all in
Argentina after 20 years of this
nonsense is pushing back Donald Trump
was pushing back there are Pockets
places like Florida that are pushing
back you should be pushing back and
might I suggest that we all go a bit
more on
offense